because i've pretty much kind of lived
with someone like my whole life and
i was scared to death of being single
that was part of the aban abandon was i
like i had no idea what it would be like
to be alone and then once i got alone i
was like wow this is fine
this is dangerous to know i can be alone
and it'd be totally fine but i realized
how like i thought i would you know i
wasn't sure how much things i did for
someone else versus what i did for me
but i was like oh yeah i really do like
things kind of tidy i like to sort of
curate the house i like things so have
you learned stuff about yourself and
being in your own space that you're like
hmm i didn't realize i had this pattern
in me or this preference
yeah definitely definitely the tidiness
because you know growing up in like in
my parents house i still kind of live
there part time as well and for some
reason like i'm so messy over there but
then when i'm at my house i like i guess
maybe it's because it's mine or because
like i just feel like a closeness to it
i'm like so
tidy about it too like i hate when
things are messy i get like itchy if
like something's out of place or like
you know if i have people over like the
second they leave i'm like cleaning
everything up like i don't like for it
to be untidy or dirty in any way
um which is weird because i always
thought i was just such a messy person
but i guess that's only in my childhood
house or in places that i guess aren't
mine
um which i feel bad for my mom about
because i'm like she's like why can't
you just be tidy at home too but i don't
know like something about being in my
own space like i actually do like to
keep it fairly
neat which is not something i expected
in myself because i always thought i was
just a very messy person i realized i
don't actually like to be in mess which
is kind of how i've lived for a while
but now even at my parents as i try to
be more tidy because now i know what
it's like to have your own home in your
own space and like what it takes to take
care of a space you know you've talked
about your music being like a mirror and
our whole life is mere really i mean
this is one of the things that i've come
to realize
reality is just mirroring back me
so if i see something that you know i
might be judging it's like oh wow i can
look at that and be like i can see that
there's something i'm denying in myself
the fact that it even registers on an
emotional level means that it's in me
um the way that people even just i mean
i've had to learn about myself through
the way that people talk about me just
because
i do the same like i haven't always had
the nicest dialogue with myself and so
when people would tell me things like
yeah okay yeah okay and then finally
after enough time you go wow okay i
think they're showing me me
and the kind of people that show up in
your life you go wow
they are showing me me too by being the
kind of people that they are across the
board um
so i want i'm like curious if you've
thought more about that and thought
about you know your life and your
reality and what it's showing you and
maybe even things are coming up in your
mind now
or
you know specifically them with your
music which is something you've said is
that your
your music is kind of like a mirror and
what have you learned from that
basically i'm wondering what all your
mirrors are
that's a great question
um that's an excellent question i mean
yeah well you know on the music side of
things of course like um i think you
know other people seeing themselves in
my music has in turn
shown me parts of myself and shown me
that
you know a lot of parts that i thought
were so foreign and so like you know out
of this world
not relatable are actually so so common
and everybody else i feel like you know
just having that dialogue with my
supporters and listeners has really just
shown me that i'm not alone but then you
know on a more personal side of things
you know in my interpersonal
relationships you know another thing i
learned like through getting older is
that nobody can like make you feel
something you know like when you say
like this person made me mad or you made
me do this it's like
no someone did something and in turn you
reacted a certain way that you chose
like you you chose to react a certain
way and so i always found myself like
you know over the years whether it's in
romantic relationships or just in people
relationships like i i make myself
smaller sometimes for other people and i
always thought it was like
you know the other person's doing like
this person made me feel small but it's
like no i allowed myself to feel small
actually i made myself smaller to
appease somebody else or to not make
someone else feel bad and so
you know all those relationships have
shown me parts of myself that i
like or like tendencies and patterns
that i was doing to myself that i
thought other people were doing to me
um and so i guess just getting older and
learning what i want and don't want has
just like allowed me to
i don't know just it showed me like what
i've allowed in my life and what i've
done to myself to appease people and
like this tendency i have to make sure
that everybody else is like okay before
myself
um so yeah i feel like that's been my
biggest pattern and my biggest tendency
that's kind of been a pattern in all of
my
relationships is like just like
shrinking myself
um for others and it actually had
nothing to do with the other person it
was it was my own thing i guess so
that's been like a huge mirror for me um
that i've tried really hard not to do
anymore um that i still tend to do but i
try not to
and they're hard patterns they start
when we're young they say that
our subconscious programming which
operates 95 percent of our life our
conscious mind is five percent of our
life and that our subconscious mind is
programmed from the last trimester
before you're born until the first like
six or maybe eight years of your life
wow i don't know about you but i
actually don't remember much before i
was even 10. so like i have no idea what
my subconscious programming was when i
was a kid i have these like images like
i don't remember
my childhood and video before that age
but i remember sort of snapshot pictures
of it um but that's a kind of scary
thing right to think that
there's that much vulnerability at that
age at an age where we can't really
ration it's like
i think about parents these days and
how hard it must be to not only is it
hard to be a parent but now if i'm sort
of putting it on them like by the way
your kid's subconscious programming is
done before they even barely have
rationing skills and you're like uh
uh so then the question is is what do
you do after that and how do you how do
you help them navigate out of it so
maybe maybe just for you what have you
learned that helps you navigate out of
it and helps you cope and helps you to
be able to
um
you know hug your inner child pay
attention to her stop for a moment and
think about how you feel
you how you feel
and to
um you know just be able to
uh
find find the good in things have you
what are the what are some techniques i
don't know if your therapist has given
you any or you've developed some maybe
writing is a big one yeah totally
writing is definitely a huge one for me
um that's just it is like a huge
coping mechanism that's just kind of how
i process
things like seeing
something on on paper like in a weird
placebo-y way like it allows me to feel
like it's out of me it's out of my
system in a sense like putting it down
you know placebo placebo is 30
so no matter what like across the board
placebo effect is about 30 percent
effective
so
it's a pretty good default yeah that's
hey not too bad so maybe i'm onto
something um yeah that's a huge one and
i think you touched on something great
too is like how much of it is mine like
what is mine and i guess i don't know if
it's a cancer thing or just the way that
i was brought up but i or i guess the
way maybe we all kind of are programmed
initially it's like to take on the
feelings of so many other people and i
think that's your blessing
yeah a lot of your pisces the cancer is
a water sign but your pisces air but you
my sister's a pisces and that girl has
some antennas for days like she knows
what's coming before i mean i don't even
know why i question her anymore but um
that's definitely i think could be very
much part of your pisces but there are
some people that definitely take on
people's emotions and that's so heavy
and confusing
definitely yeah well i mean a side note
both my parents are pisces and
particularly my mom has tons in her
chart and she is like psychic like
literally she is never wrong it's scary